okay so if any of you have met arena
uh here near the bridge of sacrifice uh
i'm not gonna go over there now because
i have progressed this quest a little
bit further so i don't want to spoil
things for you but um
i'm right here at the sight of grace
over here and then right over here on
the left side before you enter the
tunnel you see that little kind of light
area over there that's where you will
find arena
and she will actually give you a letter
that she wants you to give to her father
and her father she says is in castle
mourn well castle mourn
is going to be a little bit further
south so you see here how i've unlocked
a couple of different sites of grace
here along the way um but i'm going to
go and show you guys how you find her
father so
if you don't have any of these sites of
grace unlocked yet what you'll have to
do is just kind of make your way south
down here and head to the castle but i'm
going to go ahead and warp straight here
to the castle more and lift and i'll
show you how to get there from there
okay so here we are now at the castle
mourn lift
and that's going to bring you right here
now there's going to be a lot of enemies
up here
but for the most part you can avoid them
just by sneaking around so we're going
to ride the lift to the top and then
i'll show you how to sneak by those
enemies and how to get to her father
because
there's a couple of different paths
that are up here so your first time
through it can kind of be a little
confusing so i'll show you how to do it
here now your first couple times uh you
might try to fight these guys
they're not too terribly difficult just
make sure you watch these over here on
the left as well and then there's also
going to be some
back there but if you're trying to just
sneak through as long as you crouch you
can kind of just get by all these guys
and you can even get by the
pumpkinhead guy over here
so i'm probably just gonna speed up this
video a bit for you and get you to the
next spot
now there is a guy right here that i
just usually take off running and if you
run by him
and then you hit the stairs right here
or the ladder excuse me
sometimes he's followed me but most of
the time he will not follow you at all
he'll just stay there then you're going
to head all the way to the top here
now from here there's probably going to
be some enemies that you won't really be
able to avoid
so
depending on your level they're probably
not going to prove too difficult for you
but just you know don't get complacent
because these guys up here can
definitely still kill you especially if
you're early on in the game and you're
not
too leveled up yet
all right so took care of those guys i'm
going to go ahead and progress across
right here and i'm going to show you
where there's a site of grace now i
encourage you to explore this whole area
because there's lots of different items
there's actually a ladder just over that
way that leads to an item
and then right over here
keep going straight this way
this
right down there is another site of
grace now i haven't figured out a way to
get back up if you drop down there so
just uh be aware that if you drop down
there you will be able to activate that
side of grace but you're probably not
going to be able to get back up again
unless there is a way that
i don't know yet you see can kind of see
right there that sort of leads back in
there
but again
with the jumping mechanic of this game
some areas i'm still kind of figuring
out where you can jump to where you can
so the area that we're actually heading
for is going to be over there on the
opposite side now there's a ladder right
here or speaking of that aforementioned
jumping mechanic you could just hop off
right here not going to do any fall
damage to you now there are going to be
more enemies up here now for the most
part you can probably sneak by these
guys because they are going to be in the
middle of another fight so i'm just
going to go ahead and run past them here
and then i'm going to go up these stairs
here on the right
and right up here is where you will find
arena's father now i'm going to go ahead
and cut to
my previous run when he was actually
here because he's going to be gone now
when you guys are looking at this so
here's a shot of him showing up and so
that is where you find arena's father i
will leave it up to you if you show him
the letter or not and then let you
progress the quest further to see where
it goes from there i actually haven't
saw it through all the way to the end
yet
but it definitely takes an interesting
turn after you show him the letter and
then go back to arena so i'm gonna leave
it at that for you guys hopefully this
helped you out as always thank you all
so much for watching and i'll talk to
you again soon